Pre symposium or pre conference symposium
leading up to the in conference.
If this is the first time that you've
participated with us in the three months
prior to our annual IN conference,
we will have one webinar a month once
symposium us prepare people for the in
conference.
And so that's where we are today.
Today we are going to do an introduction
into licensing IP from the federal
government.
So thank you for coming.
Just a few housekeeping things,
I would appreciate it if you have
questions that you can put your questions
into chat.
We will be monitoring the chat and we'll
take the questions at the end of the
period.
So if you're online,
please keep your microphones on mute so
that it doesn't disrupt the panel this
morning.
So OK,
we're going to get started with a very
quick video that sounds not working from
the A or from Velocity.
I don't think my sound is working on the
board,
so if there's time we'll show it at the
end.
We're going to give you a high level
overview of what the in conference is.
Velocity has taken lead in organizing the
conference.
OK.
So the AIM summit is the health AIM
Health R&
D summit is going to be June 16th.
Originally this was scheduled as a 2 day
summit,
but in the interest of making it the most
impactful action filled conference
available,
we have condensed all of that programming
into one action filled day.
It is a very full day starting at 8:30 in
the morning on Monday, June 16th,
running until the end of the day with end
of the day networking reception that's
going to wrap up somewhere around 6:30.
So we have general sessions in the
morning looking at dual use medical
technology for operational medicine and
disaster, mass casualty,
future of bio defense.
We're taking a good look at the trauma
research and casualty care consortium
that is being set up at UT Health,
UT System consortium being LED out of UT
Health San Antonio and we're going to
take a nice deep dive into the San
Antonio federal research units that are
here.
Afternoon tracks.
We've got funding innovation,
we have working with the military,
we have selling to the military and then
we have 12 sessions of research
programming.
So we have research podium talks along
with all the rest of the programming that
we have,
talks ranging from healthy aging to wound
healing, traumatic brain injury.
There is research on that is going on
with collaborations with academia and
military on there's even some industry in
here and some private research
institutions.
And then we have our SME encounter
sessions, SME encounter sessions,
subject matter expert.
These are panel sessions that you can
sign up for and you can have a 121,
if you will, this session with a panel.
The panel is made-up of subject matter
experts from the the military units here
in San Antonio.
Each of the units is, is representative,
Navy,
Air Force and Army if it's an appropriate
topic.
We also have a representative from the VA
so that you can pitch as a company,
you can pitch your technology to them and
you can get some feedback on your
technology and the utility in that
specific organization.
So those sign up sessions are going to be
available.
If you have registered,
you'll get some Patient of Windows sign
ups are available at Velocity Texas.
They also post office hours with the DoD.
So you can go to the Velocity Texas
website and submit a request for an
appointment and you can meet with
military leaders,
research leaders from the Air Force, Army,
Sioux, Navy,
as well as with the DAG portfolio
managers that we have local.
So make note of that if you are
interested in getting some one-on-one
last time with them.
And finally,
our last free conference symposium is
going to be on May 19th.
It is a halfway to commercialization,
really a success story of collaboration
between the DHA and the industry that
provided for that assisted with the
development of some new critical medical
technology.
So before we get started with our
programming,
I'm going to hand the floor over to
Doctor Scott Walter,
Director of Technology Transfer and
Transition at the 59 Cents.
Oh, they're like that.
I owe them money.
I appreciate everyone being here today
and everyone being available online.
Also wanted to remind folks that these
sessions are being videotaped.
So if you missed something,
you can pull it up on the Washington,
Texas website.
There's also a website for the end
conference that has a lot of great
information.
So that resource is available like the
SME session.
We had a brief webinar briefing just like
this one a month ago and that one is now
available online.
So if you want more information like
check that out or engage the panel today.
And, and a lot of resources available.
Wanted to appreciate,
show appreciation for the people around
this a panel today that'll be presenting
information they're taking time on the
busy schedules to help help educate and
training us so we can be better at
engaging intellectual property that's
available from the military that helps
the military.
So on behalf of the military and I want
to say thank you for being here and
participating in this program.
Also today's session being forwarded.
Just want to make sure everyone
understands that and accepts it for the
report.
And that's more of them and then
everything here today.
I'll go ahead and give a disclaimer for
everybody that's going to be
participating so we can skip over that
With each of the presenters that that
they're providing to you is their vast
information available,
which may or may may not be reflective of
their parent organizations.
So mom and dad,
everybody else and that would work.
I wanted to ask if you have a
representative from SURF.
SURF is also being held in consumption as
part of it mean confidence.
Does anybody OK well in that I wanted to
mention a little bit about SURF.
SURF has been going on for people 11
years now but it's the San Antonio
Military Health System University
Research Forum as you are now and it was
a lot of the students who present great
information research base.
It also gives you a chance to get
interactive engagement because today and
as well as the next one that Patty
mentioned and the actual importance has
something for everyone.
There's just so much information that's
been provided,
but today it's going to give us an
introduction of the DH as venture
disclosure process.
That's very important because it helps if
you're online today or watching this
later and you're thinking about, hey,
that's a good ideas from military or my
family provider.
DHA has a great process that she'll go
over on how to get invention disclosure
submitted.
And it's an entry level.
So when we can build off that knowledge,
if you're academia,
a lot of good information today is going
to be presented on how you can work with
the military.
And when I say military,
it also includes government civilian
research to secure ID jointly.
And then the third of course is we really
want to target businesses that first make
sure you're aware of it.
We have a lot of great influential
property in devices that are used to
develop new products.
And today we're going to discuss a lot of
public engagement,
how to identify and engage and then
secure that and then also utilizing that
influential property.
And then some of your proposals,
you don't necessarily have to license it
to submit a proposal say to app works.
So that's the RSCTR,
you can reference it or you can approach
which we have a representative from.
Secondly,
today we manage a lot of our in social
property.
By the time you can add that to your
proposal that show reviewers that you've
done the research,
there's a kind of insult to property out
there that you're going to utilize.
And the other thing about military
generating social property,
there's a there's a mark because a lot of
our in social property is based on me,
the necessity that a provider,
she or he's working on something.
I wish I had this or I hadn't been this
to make them work.
That's the influential problem that can
be secure and then soon later.
So again,
appreciate everyone that's on call.
We need to keep going.
So I'm going to turn it over.
I think the first speaker is Marlena.
Marlena, can you introduce yourself,
please?
Yes.
Good morning, everyone.
Can I do a quick comms check?
Can you hear me OK?
Yes, we can hear you.
OK.
Thank you so much.
And until my bandwidth gets too weak,
I'll keep my camera on.
So all right, good morning everyone.
Thank you so much for having me today and
really quick because I think I only have
10 minutes to to give you a high level
overview,
but I'm a patent attorney at DHA Office
of General Counsel and we have a shop
that all of basically all the medical IP
or most of the medical IP coming out of
the armed forces.
So next slide, please.
OK,
so where are the medical innovations
coming from that reach our office?
And many of you will know these people
because we're in collaboration with you.
The Army provides most of the the things
that we come, that we come across,
and that's because it's a a monster of
research.
We have 10 labs,
including powers like Walter Reed Army
Institute of Research and Research
Institute of Infectious Diseases.
We have a global footprint and we do a
lot of work.
We get out, we we get a lot of IP,
believe it or not,
out of Thailand and Africa.
We also support the Air Force.
They have a number of labs, the Navy,
we will probably be supporting them and
uniformed services,
typo should be services.
University has a training facility and we
get a lot out of there.
And of course,
DHA has lots of hospitals and,
but most of the IP,
if any come out of the medical training
facilities.
OK,
that's and and many of you will be
already in knowledgeable of these places
because you're in collaborations with
some of our labs.
All right, next slide please.
So what is the life cycle of army or
medical, any sort of military medical IP?
Well,
this is a really simple slide because I
only had a few minutes,
but just so you can see how it how we see
it and you could fit in nicely here,
I think.
So our medical research will hopefully
lead to an innovation and then we our
office gets involved right away as we
like to get involved as soon as possible
because we're trying to forego or get
ahead of any publications and just also
work with any of our partners.
So where it goes with there.
So we'll engage our process in the next
slides.
We'll tell talk about that a little bit,
but you can see that we will also engage
without licensing and my esteemed
colleague Barry Datloff will inform you
of that in a little bit.
We'd have some capability to develop a
little bit in house.
We actually have officer regulated
activity and that can be an FDA sponsor.
But as you all know, we we don't want it.
We don't go too far with that.
We really need,
I'd like to work with academia and
industry to have commercial partners and
if necessary even a procurement contract
contract.
So at the end of that,
you can see the nice blue text.
It's a field of medical capability and
that's always our goal.
OK, next slide please.
All right.
So what is our process?
And I think this slide got a little
messed up,
but I'll try to read through it.
So we have rather a robust process and I
haven't actually heard of been working
with them for over 30 years on 25 years.
Sorry,
I don't want to date myself too much and
and I haven't seen anything like it
really in the DoD anyway.
So we have an invention intake team and
I'm part of that,
I supervise some of that.
And we have a robust process with our
invention disclosure forms like many of
you have for your institutions as well.
And we do a lot of work before it goes
anywhere.
And we'll see if it's sufficiently
developed, you know,
what is the technology readiness level.
And if it looks like it's, hey, we,
we got something here,
we have some decent data and we'll make
sure some of the so,
so we package it up so that it makes
sense.
I'll also do an inventorship assessment.
And as everyone knows,
ownership follows inventorship.
And the relevance of that is if we have a
partner such as somebody that we have a
crater with,
they could probably will be a co-owner.
And so then we'll get into, you know,
buy Dole rights,
which is a whole nother slideshow,
but I'll we'll handle all that and we
work with anyone we transfer over if it's
a vital, if they elect title,
then our process is going to stop and
we'll work with the the partner to get
them on board.
So either way,
we're pretty robust about it.
So after that,
let's just say it it gets gets where it
should go.
So it'll get, if it passes all that,
it'll be put in our queue for the
Invention Evaluation Committee.
And we meet about once a month,
sometimes if necessary, twice.
And this takes several hours and lots of
resources and time.
Go into that meeting,
we'll have a prior art search
commissioned.
I will do a patentability assessment
based on that.
We will assess licensing potential and
and Barry will talk a little bit about
that.
So it's really a team effort.
Our inventors get involved.
We have a lot of meetings outside of that
in advance of the meeting.
And then we'll have a large committee
meeting and we will all discuss
everything and come to a consensus.
Some of the things about what to do.
So some of the things you look obviously
is as likely patentable.
If I have a bad search report, you know,
I'm going to have to tell them.
But we usually try to work at least we'll
see the priority.
We'll work around it if we can see what
we have.
So what we can reasonably expect,
because we're going to pour a lot of
resources into it.
Is it licensable?
Barry's team will assess this.
And we consider things like,
does it fulfill a military mission?
And we really like it when it's dual use.
And you can imagine that most medical IP
often has at least civilian use as well.
And that's really fantastic because it
just gets the science that world do the
most good software.
We we have a couple options for software.
Sometimes a patent isn't the best way if
that's the main component of the
innovation.
At the end of the process,
at the end of the meeting,
I should say we've decided one way or the
other.
Usually we're going to go forward and
file or maybe not.
So a lot of resources go into our process
and we it's working out pretty well.
We we still have room to grow,
especially given the fact that we are
processing more and more these days.
OK, next slide please.
All right.
So just a little bit of context for
metrics, if anyone likes those numbers.
So it comes perhaps we get to,
to me usually, often the researchers,
they, they know us by now.
They'll just send me an e-mail and say,
hey, I think I have something.
Our wonderful orders,
our lab tech transfer teams are also on
top of it.
And we in the past couple years,
we've also started pre publication
reviews,
scanning for anything that looks like
it's something we ought to pay attention
to.
And this takes a lot of time as well.
We do hundreds of these a year.
What comes out is about after we've
curated everything about,
I'll say about 70 invention disclosure
forms a year.
And most of those, not all,
but most of those end up getting filed
upon because we've tried to curate them
down.
So by the time it hits the IEC meeting
that we were pretty good and then the
patent applications filed is about 100 a
year and why there's a disparity between
70 and 100 is not a one to one.
As you probably know,
these may split one invented disclosure
may split into multiple jurisdictions
such as you know,
if we file in the US which we would and
we might file also in Europe or other
jurisdictions from there.
So we're we're pretty busy shop overall.
Next slide, please.
So I was suggested that you might want to
know what,
what about our inventors or anyone's
inventors.
So if it's the US inventors,
that's what I who I deal with most of the
time.
Are they obligated to assign their rights
to the inventions to the US government?
And yes,
almost always because their invention,
if they're made during the normal course
of their job,
then employers usually like to reap the
fruit of their employees work.
And usually that's OK with everybody
because that's why they're working there.
They're very happy to work with us.
And so and Canon.
But but sometimes, you know,
can an inventor ever keep an invention
they've made in the course of their
employment?
At least for the US government.
And everyone has their own employment
contract, of course.
But in the US government, yes,
sometimes it's possible to do that,
but it is a process.
We, we're very,
we have a as like everything in the Army
military, we have a process, but we have,
we've done this before.
And as a fact of fact, recently,
very recently,
we're in the process of licensing back a
bench scientist's invention back to him.
And he has a he's retired and he has a
spin off company and he's going to
develop it and we're happy to help him do
that.
So I think I've reached a probably a
little over my 10 minutes, but next slide,
please.
And I think that should be the end.
All right.
Well, I will think we'll hold questions,
right.
So I will so wait for any questions if
any and we can just move on to the next
guest.
Thank you, Marlene.
Yes, we are holding questions to the end,
but all questions into the chat and we
will take them at the end.
So thank you for that for your
presentation.
Our next presenter is Malcolm Cole.
He is with Teckling and very important
that program, excuse me,
with the military for binding and
licensees through there too.
Go ahead, Mel.
Thanks.
Quick, quick mic check.
Can you hear me OK?
Yes, perfect.
Well,
thanks Patty and Nicole for the
invitation to speak and for setting up
this webinar.
And hi, everyone.
Thanks for coming to this.
My name is Malcolm.
I'm a senior technology manager with
Techlink.
We're a partnership intermediary
supporting the Department of Defense as
well as the VA.
And kind of the,
the focus of my talk is how,
how can you find new opportunities to
collaborate with the DoD or to, you know,
harness innovations coming out of the
federal government for the work that your
own company is doing.
And we'll kind of go through a couple of
approaches that that that I've found
success with.
A little bit about my organization.
Next slide.
So Tech Link is an authorized partnership
intermediary.
We support both the DoD and the VA.
We work with companies that are
interested in partnering with those
organizations both in identifying
technologies of interest.
We also provide support throughout the
licensing process,
which I'll get into on the next slide.
We are fully funded through a contract
with the Air Force, our home institution,
Montana State University and the Office
of the Under Secretary of Defense.
So all of our services are provided to
both the labs we support and to companies
that work with us at no cost.
And we have about 50 individuals,
wide range of backgrounds.
Most of our technology managers have PhDs
or some sort of scientific background as
well as significant licensing experience.
Next slide.
So our our process,
we support you throughout the technology
transfer process.
The kind of focus in my talk today will
be discovering opportunities to work with
DoD IP.
We also help you evaluate that IP for
your company's needs,
apply for a license agreement or other
intellectual property agreements to
actually work with the labs and we help
you through the negotiation of those
agreements as well.
We kind of serve as like a third party
honest broker to support both of you and
the lab tech transfer office.
But as I said today,
focus will be on this first step
discovering IP next slide.
So how to find opportunities for
collaboration.
So let's say you're interested in Co
developing new IP or maybe you have a
product or some background IP that you'd
like to work with a lab to help validate
there.
There's a few,
I'd say good resources to to find these
opportunities.
One is research lab websites.
So here is the Air Force research labs
website.
Next slide.
Here is the website for the Army research
lab.
And next slide and here's for Army
Medical's web page.
Generally these are if you kind of just
Google the lab and look for something
that says collaborate or working with the
lab from a businesses perspective,
the labs will generally post a lot of
opportunities for collaboration,
specific projects or specific capability
gaps that they're looking to fill.
So these are really gonna be your best
resource to find those types of
opportunities.
Next slide, for licensing,
there's a couple resources you can use,
Barry.
In the next portion,
we'll talk about the Medical Tech
Transfer group supporting DHA,
their website,
which has a great repository of Army
Medical or DHA specific IP on their
website.
But I'd like to present another resource
that you can use, which is our website,
techniquecenter.org.
Next slide.
So here's our homepage and our website.
One of our duties as a partnership
intermediary is to maintain a catalog of
all DoD and VAIP that's been published.
So it's close to 7000 patents that we
maintain on our website and we have a
searchable database.
If you go to our web page,
this is kind of the first thing you'll
see.
You can do a high level search.
But if you go to the next slide,
we also have a number of filters that you
can use to help refine this.
So if you look on the left,
you can filter by technology area.
You can also highlight feature
technologies.
What this generally means is these are
technologies that we've identified as
being of high potential commercial
interest,
very ready for licensing and we actually
prepare all of these technologies have a
essentially just the abstract from the
patent post on our website.
But if we identify it as a priority or
feature technology,
we'll also prepare a non confidential
summary essentially like a marketing
abstract.
These also have links to publications,
other related patents.
So the kind of featured IP has maybe a
bit more information to provide some
additional background.
You can also filter by technologies that
have express licensing available.
And this is essentially predetermined
licensing fees that have been set by the
laboratory and they're usually pretty
reasonable, you know,
one or $2000 upfront and a low single
digit royalty.
So that can express license technologies
can really expedite the process and you
can also in that search by technologies,
you can search by you know keyword,
area of interest, etcetera.
Next slide.
So here for example,
we've filtered to medical technologies
that have that are featured so that have
a little bit more of a write up and we've
included the search term for vaccine.
Let's say you're a vaccine interested
company and let's take a closer look at
this first technology related to
antivirus.
Next slide.
So here's what the kind of the featured
technology breakdown looks like.
It has a high level executive summary of
the technology may be a relevant picture,
some bullet point benefits specifically,
you know what are advantages over the
state-of-the-art over competitors.
The opportunity will kind of highlights,
is this an opportunity for collaboration?
Is this a technology that's actually
ready for licensing might speak to the
technology readiness level.
And then if if there's associated
scholarly articles or news articles,
we'll link those here.
And then we also have a link to all the
associated patents.
So really a kind of a one stop shop for
this piece of IP really centralizes all
of the information.
You don't have to, you know,
go to Google patents and then track down
publications.
It's all contained right here.
Next slide.
So if you click on that,
speak with an expert,
it'll it'll pull up this survey to input
some information about your company,
kind of identify your areas of interest
in terms of technology domains and your
contact information.
And there's also this check box at the
bottom that I encourage you to click.
This subscribes you to our newsletter,
The Pulse and this will highlight new
technology opportunities in the areas
that you identified and we'll send them
to you automatically.
As I said,
one of our roles as a partnership in new
area is to constantly evaluate new DoD
and VAIP as it gets published.
And so the kind of the fastest way to
learn about those opportunities is to
subscribe to our newsletter.
Next slide and here's here's what that
looks like.
This is one we recently put out for our
World Health Day related to maternal and
neonatal healthcare,
which you probably wouldn't normally
think of as a priority area for the DoD,
but there actually is a good amount of IP
in this space.
And so subscribing to our newsletter
would be a great way to to kind of learn
about those opportunities.
Next slide,
a couple other things that we have on our
website.
We'll post news articles,
essentially success stories,
so you can see how other companies have
successfully leveraged DODIP to, you know,
fulfill capability gaps or bring products
to the market.
And we also have some business focus
articles that might have, you know,
advice about working with the DoD.
And I mentioned the newsletter on the
previous slide, But if you're, you know,
a bit wary about cluttering up your inbox,
we also have an A LinkedIn page where
we'll post a lot of our news article
articles and technology spotlights.
So you can also just follow us on
LinkedIn if if the newsletter is,
you know, maybe a bit too much.
Next slide.
So I really just want to kind of the main
take away I want from my portion is if
you're interested in DoD IP,
recommend visiting our website at
techlinkcenter.org.
But we're also all technology managers
are resource for you.
And so let's say you're not,
you maybe don't have time to do an in
depth search of our website or, you know,
all DODIP,
but you are interested in working with
the DoD,
you want to hear more about potential
opportunities to do so.
Just reaching out to our office,
either to me,
my emails right there or coming in
through our web page.
Our,
our contact field has some of our
information.
Just just reach out to us and and we can
do a lot of the like work to,
to try and identify those technologies of
interest for you as well.
So next slide, I think is just Yep.
So, so that's it for me.
Thanks for the opportunity.
And I think Barry is up.
Barry Datloff is up next.
Thank you so much.
Thank you so much, Malcolm.
Today,
I'd like to talk about licensing the
intellectual property of DHA.
I'm Barry Detloff,
the Chief of Business Development and
Commercialization.
Next slide, usual disclaimer.
Next slide.
All right.
Everybody knows DHA does healthcare.
A lot of folks are unaware of the
specific areas.
There was a slide previously with a huge
number of them.
We like to keep it simple.
Vaccines, therapeutics, diagnostics,
devices and medical IT.
There's plenty more where that came from,
but I'll talk about a few next slide.
So military operational medicine is
really our bread and butter,
especially down in San Antonio,
Combat casualty care with ISR and Bamsey
and the 59th,
we do a lot of blood resuscitation,
etcetera.
And up at Fort Dietrich and at Walter
Reed Army Institute of Research,
a lot of infectious disease.
Easiest way sometimes to find what you're
looking for is Medline, believe it or not,
search for Army, Navy,
Air Force and the words that you're
looking for.
Next slide, please.
So we have a phrase called assistive
technology transfer,
because it's not a linear process.
People come in to DHA at different times
of development,
whether they're looking for a creative
partner, funding from the DoD,
need help with a prototype or testing it
in the field,
or actually just need some clinical
regulatory guidance for something that
will be worn by or used by the war
fighter.
As always,
intellectual property is the basis for
licensing.
And I'll talk in a little bit about the
expansion that's been occurring slowly
but surely for not just patents,
but copyrights, trademarks, etcetera.
But the goal of assist of T2 is singular
military products.
If we have civilian sales, all the better.
The price the military pays goes down and
the company has sustainability.
We need to get these products not just
invented and researched,
we need to get them purchased so the war
fighter has them available to mitigate
any problems.
Next slide.
So I am a flow diagrammer by avocation.
What can I tell you?
Programmers never can get away from flow.
They're usually three things that you're
looking for when you knock on our door.
If indeed you're a company or
collaborating,
not-for-profit or universities,
you need money.
You want to collaborate with us or you're
actually ready to sell your product.
And getting to the right folk is your
challenge as well as mine.
We get a lot of phone calls,
a lot of emails from companies saying,
hey, I got this, are you interested?
So this sort of allows us to divvy it up
into three different groups.
There are always new and old ones,
no longer with money,
sources of funding for research.
There's an entire sheet that we keep,
we hope up to date.
If you have new ones, add to it for me.
But we really specialize in collaborating
through our DHA labs and our MTFS for
everything from clinical trials to basic
R&
D on some of the pathogens and or medical
conditions that we're charged with on the
right is actually the hardest thing for
us folks in the labs to garner all the
resources around.
And that is how do you sell back to DHA.
The sooner the company can sell,
the more sustainable that product is in
the marketplace.
And we'd like to be the first purchaser,
can't guarantee that we will be.
And when we do R&D with a company,
we can't even guarantee that we'll buy it.
So it's still got to be best of breed and
priced reasonably.
But our DHA vendor days up at for
Dietrich virtual and in person our MHSRS
conference really important places to be
to get the SMEs gathered together who are
going to support getting this either a
direct commercial off the shelf
acquisition or into the DLA warehouse
with the national stock number NSN.
So this is our lay of the land.
We hope it helps.
Next slide,
we work with a lot of third parties and
there's Techlink famous as one of our
outstanding PS.
You can see that it does literally take a
village and everybody has different part
in that process.
We don't work with everybody
simultaneously on one project,
but sometimes there are folks out there
in DoD land,
elsewhere in the government that we can
bring into the partnership with a company
that knocks on our door.
And I'll leave it to Malcolm to define
every single one of these acronyms.
Actually, Scott needs to be able to.
We'll have a contest next time I see that.
Thumbs up.
Next slide, please.
So we don't call it the Valley of Death,
we call it the Bridge of Hope.
And our goal along with our friends at
Techlink,
at Velocity and all the funding kind of
vehicles is to get companies off of their
sort of traditional bleeding red ink into
going green at some point.
And that happens at different stages for
medical devices then, for instance,
therapeutics or vaccines.
But this bridge of hope really
encompasses the understanding on the part
of startup companies of how much is
available at each of these stages.
And of course,
this varies based on who's talking to you,
how much they actually have in the bank
versus they'd like to have in the bank
and due diligence as Ken.
Next slide.
Here's the federal funding list I was
noting before.
I believe empty is swinging in the breeze
at the moment.
So I don't think they're currently
funding anything.
We'd like to have a few more.
If any of you on the call are venture
capitalists and would like to start ADOD
Biomedical Venture Fund, give me a call.
Next slide, previously shown next slide.
So what's a license?
Well,
it's not an FDA license that we're
talking about here.
We're talking about how to get the right
to use the patents, copyrights,
trademarks, the traditional tech transfer.
But our materials are know how,
even our trade secrets,
even though Army hates the word,
Navy loves the word.
All of that stuff is what we call other
intellectual property and companies can
come to us and say, hey,
I'd like to evaluate what you have there.
It may be for six months that we just
need to kick the tires.
It may be that you're locked and loaded,
ready to take a patent license agreement.
You're going to do a round of financing.
Having it in your portfolio is a good
idea before the investors give you money.
But we also do software licensing,
which doesn't even require there to be a
patent.
It's under what we call 801.
Software licensing materials are,
you might say a dime a dozen,
but you'd be amazed at how many of the
pathogens frozen in our labs are still of
great value, if not ten years,
50 years or 100 years after they've been
collected.
Next slide.
So what's a typical license look like?
And I appreciate Patty having asked this
question because as always,
people want to know how fast can I get a
license?
And I don't want to pay a lot for this
muffler.
I mean, license, you know what I mean?
So typical deals we wish we could do.
Express licensing for everything we can't.
A vaccine or a cure for COVID versus a
medical device to keep my snoring down.
They've got to be priced differently,
timed differently, etcetera.
We ask companies to give an upfront
license fee as part of our due diligence
that they actually have a bank account
because we need to be able to access
future funds via such as well.
And the proceeds are shared with the
inventors long before there's a product
in the marketplace.
When inventors decide how how much work
can they afford,
how much time can they afford to work on
something,
It's always a little bit tied to is there
a product at the end of the rainbow or is
the license basically just there for
eternity, which we don't let it be.
We have minimum annual royalties.
That's to make sure you're still in
business.
We ask for the patent cost to be
reimbursed over time,
but the real big chunk comes when there
are products that are sold.
Royalties on product sales are according
to industry standards with what I'll call
government standard discounts.
In other words,
we're not there to break you over the
Kohl's.
We need the product foremost and so our
royalties on product sales are usually
backloaded a little bit on the time frame
you succeed,
we expect to succeed in the beginning.
We want your money to be spent on
marketing and even second generation
product development milestone payments.
Like I said, if you just get FDA approval,
your company's worth more,
you'll pay us back some of the money that
you normally would have paid upfront,
but we decreased in amount sublicensing.
Similarly,
most biotechs can't go to the worldwide
market themselves and sublicense to a
pharma for vaccines and therapeutics and
frequently that's for money upfront as
well as a royalty stream.
We asked for discounts on purchases by
DoD if indeed we're integral to the
development of the product,
not if it's just sort of a straight up
intellectual property non financial
compensation may be the provision of
cleaned up versions of what we send you
if you ultra purify or use subclone or
something of the sort.
DoD has the ability to take equity,
but we only do it in times when the
company requests it for their assistance
in raising capital.
We don't do it ourselves for financial
purposes.
We want to make sure that our licensees
are well capitalized.
Timing is really for a license anything
from three weeks I think was our shortest
to three years.
And the reason it sometimes does take
three years,
technology that we have might not
actually be ready for prime time.
You might do a commercial evaluation
license,
take a look at it and say it's really not
optimal in our hands and we tell you hey
we're optimizing it.
So from beginning to end,
it may actually take a period of time to
make sure that we can get you what you
actually need to get to the commercial
marketplace.
Next slide,
our team up at Fort Dietrich as well as
down in San Antonio and actually
worldwide we have licensing professionals.
Next slide,
we put all our contact information here
is for a reason and that's we need you to
call us when you have a question.
I know it's one of the hardest things to
do to find who you're going to call.
I'll end at that point and thank you for
your time and attention this afternoon.
Thank you, Barry, thank you for that.
These slides will be available.
So all of this contact information,
you don't have your hands after this
participation.
Next up is Greg Sullivan from Tremonti.
What we're introducing is the problem
that we continue to have is matching
almost like a guidance service of
intellectual property to potential
licenses and in reverse as well.
So for a place to identify that there are
consultant services and available to that
our specializes,
we specialize in medical intellectual
problems.
So, you know,
I'm just seeing some questions being
posted.
We're wrapping up soon and we'll get to
your questions.
Thank you.
So thank you.
I hope you even look great.
Thanks.
OK, Julie.
Yeah.
Hi.
You take it over.
Yeah.
My name is Julie Nagle.
I'm with Trevani Consulting and thank you
for having us today.
And my colleague, you just heard,
Greg Sullivan,
will be joining me in this presentation
team.
So today we're going to talk about the
many problems that we face in tech
transfer and innovation,
getting those great technologies noticed
and into the hands of the people that
could make them into products and
services that change lives everyday.
Next slide, please.
And here's our disclaimer.
Next slide, please.
So Tremonti's worked across tech transfer
ecosystem for more than two decades.
We just had our 20th anniversary in fact.
And we support universities, hospitals,
federal labs,
everyone that's trying to translate their
intellectual property portfolio to the
marketplace.
We're a team of licensing professionals.
We have entrepreneurial backgrounds,
IP strategy backgrounds and our work
spans all sectors and we've closed
hundreds of deals.
What we bring is not just experience,
but an understanding of where the pain
points are because we've all been in the
trenches and seen the pain points up
close and personal.
Currently have about 250 active clients
worldwide.
Next slide.
So the reality of what we're dealing with
is pretty stark.
95% of all in disclosed inventions never
get licensed.
You know,
a lot of them don't get protected either.
So I'm just a reflection of the science
or the inventor.
It's a result of limited outreach
capacity, some generic messaging,
and really the dawn of AI flooding all of
our inboxes with information and lack of
people power.
Tech transfer offices are stretched
pretty thin and a lot of cold marketing
techniques are put in place as a result.
And they really just a lot of times don't
go anywhere.
So those are a lot of problems that we're
up against as we try to translate these
great technologies to into the right
hands that can work through the
commercialization process.
OK.
Technology transfer professionals are
dealing with mounting disclosure volumes
and they don't have the staff or
marketing support to really tailor each
technologies that they see into the hands
of the folks that can do something with
it.
Our clients tell us a lot of times we're
so busy we're just reacting.
We don't have the ability to strategize.
We don't have the bandwidth to pursue
targeted leads and find those leads and
tell our story effectively.
That's really structural challenges.
They're not unique to anyone institution.
We see that across our client base.
I I just have one thing to add.
What's interesting about marketing today
versus pre pandemic?
Prior to the pandemic you could reach
your perspective targets via by e-mail
and potentially even office phone.
Post pandemic it's nobody answers the
office phone anymore.
Too many robo calls.
Same case with e-mail.
E-mail is now dominated by AI bots that
are flooding the the their e-mail boxes.
So we've actually kind of reverted in the
marketplace back to traditional marketing
and traditional networking.
Sort of kind of the value of this
particular meeting is to actually meet,
go back and meet people and have
relationships.
Our firm is 20 years old in this space,
so we've maintained our relationships
throughout the years.
Oh, next slide.
So, oh, I'm sorry, you were already there.
I apologize.
You'd already switched.
Yeah.
So to move on to external partners,
this is really where working with an
external firm can be helpful and add
value.
We don't replace internal teams,
but we amplify their reach.
We bring our network in to find contacts
and target technologies.
So we bring that marketing horsepower,
objectivity, storytelling ability.
We know how to communicate with
scientists,
our scientists and we also speak the
language of the market.
So we can help with that business
development bridge that you saw earlier.
And we help institutions build meaningful
curated content.
And we, as Greg said,
we don't send out the cold emails into
the void.
It's really a person to person networking
and really doing those,
finding the you know what curated list of
companies that would be appropriate for
that technology and understanding why and
then making contacts with those companies.
OK, now next slide.
So here's our process.
It's structured, but it's adaptable,
begins with understanding the technology
and identifying the real market fit.
We build technology marketing materials.
You'll see an example of one that was
created for a client there.
And then we really look to see what
companies would we want to send that to.
And we prioritize that based on, you know,
what they've done in the past,
market research.
And then we do personalized outreach as
Greg mentioned earlier and we track those
data and we continue to refine and learn
from that over time is we re look for new
contacts for companies we haven't found
homes for.
So this allows us to consistently build
some momentum instead of consistent,
instead of consistently going back the
same companies that just aren't ever
going to buy early stage technologies.
OK.
Next slide and why it works.
It's focused,
it's driven on networks and conversations.
It's not just promoting technology to the
void.
We've all,
everybody at Termani's had a lot of
industry experience and we're able to
tailor the messaging down because of that.
And follow-ups key.
As Greg says,
it's hard to find some people that work
at home and work remotely and are in the
office sometimes,
not in the office sometimes.
So persistence and follow up have been
really important as we've gone through
this change back to more traditional
marketing.
And most deals don't come from a single
touch point where you talk to him once
and it ends with the licensing.
It's a pretty long conversation.
OK.
So we're getting the right message to the
right audience at the right time.
So next slide.
So how we can or any consultant can
support you through the marketing process,
It really spans past outreach.
We help with identifying targets,
narrowing down those and prioritizing
those targets,
Relationship development that we bring to
the table.
We can look at comparative transactions
in a similar space.
You see an example of one of those
reports that we do on the screen.
We help with term sheets and developing
those first,
those first terms that you put in front
of the partner all the way out to
licensing, negotiation,
evaluations of the technologies.
We can help through that entire process
or any piece there in that a client might
need help with.
So we really act as an extension of your
team.
You know when your internal capability is
limited or you have tight timelines could
help to have another person there running
this with you.
Next slide.
So this is a case study and I, you know,
I could give you more than one of these,
but this is a recent one that we have
sometimes technology sent to us saying
the inventor just wants you to push this
out here one more time.
Let's just see if there's any traction
one more time.
We haven't gotten any traction on this
technology and this was one of those.
They just wanted one more push before
they closed it.
So we looked at their marketing materials
and we're like do you care if we revamp
all of those?
And they said no,
just do what you need to do.
We redid the non confidential summary in
a slide deck.
We researched what companies we should
target and we really narrowed it down to
about 40.
There might even have been 35 and
understood why they were on that list.
And that led to two industry
conversations.
One of them led to Accreda and some more
sponsored research to further develop
that technology while it was still in the
institution.
We did a comparative transaction report
for them,
so they kind of knew what they were
looking at going into a term sheet and
where to start.
We helped him construct that term sheet
and now they're in licensing negotiations.
So that's a case study of how we came in
and augmented and helped on a technology
that had really been stuck.
But through our market assessment,
we thought we could probably find it a
home and we don't really understand why
it was stuck and they weren't moving.
So working together in partnership,
we were able to move that technology to
the licensing stage.
OK.
Next slide.
So there's a lot of tools that we deploy
to make this happen.
One is marketing briefs.
These are one pagers that you've probably
seen as in CDs.
We're moving more to licensing decks too,
so we can show more data,
especially in therapeutics that's
important.
So you know where you are in the
preclinical stage.
We use it as CRM to really track our
contacts and how they how how it was
their uptake to technology or they just
one that never respond and never call
back or they have are they really warm to
technologies.
And then we can mark in there too who we
know personally through our networks to
be able to get information back on
technologies and that real time industry
feedback is critical.
So this is an example of a marketing
report that we give at the end of every
campaign.
So we give a lot of those data and
analytics back to the client so they
understand what the markets kind of
saying about their technology.
Not always positive,
but not always negative either.
The next slide.
So here's an ideal collaboration model
and you know there's third nuance to
every client.
This is the typical rubric.
The client chooses the technology and the
goals for the technology and we Co
develop a message and a strategy therein.
And that curated list that we're going to
target that I've talked about a number of
times we are in,
we're in communication with the client
about what we're hearing from the market
and providing regular updates.
And then with a final report with the
analytics you just saw,
that's a process that's scalable across
sectors.
And you can have one technology marketing
or you can have 10s of we've had even
more than I think 80's,
the largest I've had from one client.
So it's very scalable to depending on the
size of your portfolio.
OK, next slide.
So I want you to take away from this that
using that warm technology approach after
the advent of AI,
after the pandemic has really borne more
fruit for us than the cold marketing
techniques that were ramping up during
that time.
With the right partners,
you can really scale and you can get more
of your technologies in front of the
right people for some feedback.
So you can go back to your inventors and
say this is what the market's saying.
It can help drive their research in a
different way,
can lead to sponsored research.
There's all different areas that that can
lead to when you develop partnerships
with companies and those partnerships
that we're finding are taking a more
personal touch these days and didn't in
the past.
So building that bridge between research
and the corporate community takes
teamwork and is bringing external
partners in helps you do that.
The only thing that I have to add to
Julie's presentation is that our
objective is to move those relationships
to you so that you have them when we're
done.
We leave you with those market contacts
and those relationships moving forward.
Yeah, thank you.
Thank you,
Greg and Julie for that presentation and
for all our presenters here today.
So at this point,
we have a few minutes that we can take
some questions and I know that we have
some questions online.
So why don't we take a question online
and then I'll ask the question is.
The question is,
can someone clarify when the next
upcoming medical vendor gave will be the
event?
Did you guys hear that question?
Yeah, this is Barry Detloff.
Steve Burroughs used to handle it for
Medlock up at Fort Detrick.
I just emailed him and of course,
he's either taken a Vera visa or another
job.
So I'll see if I can dig up who at
Medlog's still working there and we'll
pass that back through.
Aim for distribution to the attendees,
unless somebody else knows who's
responsible for the DHA vendor days
anymore.
Thanks, Barry.
OK, thanks.
Barry.
Is there a question in the group?
You have a question in the room.
Yeah, OK.
So we'll take the next question online.
Could you advise whether Techlink,
DHA or Tremont,
he dealt with the IP generated from the
Paralyzed Veterans of America Research
Foundation.
If not,
which agency would provide the services
or to bring the development to
commercialization invested from the
foundational investments?
I can take this one, Yancheng,
if you could provide the specific patent
or IP portfolio you're speaking on,
that would be helpful.
From techniques perspective,
kind of where our jurisdiction ends is if
it's assigned to Department of Defence or
the VA.
And so I'm not sure if this PBARF assigns
to the VA or if they own the IP
themselves.
So from our perspective,
that's where it would kind of what would
delineate whether or not we can support.
But if you share that with me,
I can definitely look into that.
I can also interject Tremonti,
we're not restricted.
We are a private entity and we work,
we're on the,
we're veteran owned and on the GSA list.
We work across all the agencies and we we
would love to take a look at your IP as
well and see how we can assist you.
Feel free to e-mail Julie or me.
Thank you.
Thank you for the questions online,
thank you for joining us online.
Thank you for joining us in the room,
and thank you to the presenters for all
of your information.
All of you have your contact information
on your slide decks and you will all get
copies of the slide deck.
So feel free to reach out to our
presenters if you have any additional
questions that would you like to say?
Oh, just one,
two quick items from the another plug in
for the actual incumbents on 16th June.
And that there's two sessions that were
mentioned today on console products and
military and also establishing the Preda
because another advantage is that you,
if you're licensing the technology,
more than likely you'll be able to
establish a Preda so you can actually
work with the inventors if you're still
employed by the government.
Thank you.
And the agenda for the in conference is
online, so you can take a look at that.
It's at aimsats.com,
so you can look at all the great
programming.
So with that,
I would like to close out the day.
I look forward to seeing you again in May.
May 19th is our next webinar.
Have a good day.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Hey, thank you.
I don't know why it was no sound on the
velocity.
It was being broadcast, it was being,
it was being,
but it doesn't really work without sound.
No,
I don't think it was any sound online
either.
There was sound inside the road that went
very well.
Thank you.
It isn't good to see you.
Thank you for all your support.
Oh, absolutely.
Yeah.
Maybe we'll be there.
Yeah, it's good.
It will be.
So you are.